[Music]
outraged this evening after racist
images and comments made at a
conservative political event this is
video from a ccw event held at a local
library on sunday in attendance several
nevada republicans running for office
now we do want to warn you the following
clips are offensive
firearm safety is no joke always with a
wife peter on the range
and always make sure there are no
minorities in your backdrop
all your shoots are done right side up
[Music]
always leave the chicken grease off your
fingers before shooting
always make sure there's a white person
around so you have someone to blame for
everything that goes wrong in your life
and always date for small children to
ensure you actually hit another gang
member
the i-team reaching out to the
candidates who attended the event
including north las vegas mayor john lee
and assemblyman tom roberts roberts who
was running for clark county sheriff
says he spoke at the event but was not
present during that portion he also says
that is something he wouldn't use nor
condone lee is running for governor so
far we've received no response at this
time the i-team also reaching out to the
instructor he sent us this statement due
to time constraints at the event i
sincerely regret i wasn't able to poke
fun at more of my friends